what is it like working with a legend
well I'm a good person to ask because I
knew um and this is how I know I was
sitting in my kitchen in North London
and all my stories will have this
slightly parochial taste to them out
talking about a film I was making for
children called Nanny McPhee and someone
said Oh who's going to play the vile
aunt Adelaide and someone I think it was
our producer said them well of course it
would be wonderful to get Miss Angela
Lansbury and I said don't be ridiculous
that's like asking for a small slice of
the moon to be delivered and let's move
on and we moved on I think to Peter
O'Toole
almost immediately and anyway we we in
the end just out of well sheer audacity
sent the script and heard much to our
astonishment that she was interested and
and then thought to our further
astonishment that she was on a plane and
coming and we all went into an immediate
panic did not know what to do or what to
expect and and then she arrived and one
of the first things that happened was
she came with me to my sister's house a
terraced house in North London where we
had a lunch for the children on Mother's
Day and she sat with us and she sang
bobbing along and all the adults at the
great tears
rolling down their cheeks and all the
children sat there as though they died
and gone to heaven and that was lunch
buggered for the rest of our lives
because as a lunch guest she's kind of
tentpole my sister and I've staged
entire musicals since then and nothing
has ever come up to scratch she arrived
on set found me in my dressing room
scrubbing at my teeth I'm sure you all
know how much trouble we have with them
in my country and she said what are you
doing I said I'm trying to erase the tea
stains from my here just hear it gathers
just here I don't know I think it's
because I strained the you know the
leaves through my teeth
she said you you have to use vim this
isn't really vim ladies and gentlemen is
a scouring powder we use for toilets in
my country it worked I have never looked
back so the day came on set when a very
large props man very the top in his
field came to me and said I've got to
throw a pie at her I've got to throw pie
at Angela Lansbury it's got a hit her in
the face I can't do it I can't do it
I'm not kidding he really couldn't do it
I said what do you mean you can't you're
a props man for heaven sakes get a grip
he said it as a green pie I can't I
can't please please don't make me I said
isn't there someone in your team who
could help none of them were willing so
finally they said you're gonna have to
do it so I went to Angela where are you
where is she yeah I went to you ang and
I said would it be all right if I threw
a pie at you and you said I'd rather it
with you it was a green pie
you sat there and I got behind the
camera and I spoke to that PI I was like
obi-wan Kenobi with Luke Skywalker I
said to that pi feel the force don't for
God's sake please don't blind her I was
so scared and used that there and I
threw the pie and it left my hand and I
swear to you it was not me that took
that pie straight smack into your face
it was some other force the force of
glory because you are the same glorious
incandescent and wonderful girl that you
have always been and use that there with
this pie rolling down your face it into
your lap and you burst out laughing and
you spent the rest of the afternoon
throwing food at the rest of the cast
and that's why you are a legend and
always will be and why that little slice
of moon came into our lives and is still
and always will be shining